20 vous sauve ou rentrait tout juste de
kiev vous étiez notre envoyé spécial
pour france 24 comment se déroulent les
enquêtes actuellement mais les enquêtes
sont elles sont extrêmement compliquées
déjà il faut savoir que c'est la
première fois que les enquêteurs
internationaux enquête sur ce genre de
ce qu'on soupçonne et des crimes de
guerre avant même que la guerre soit
terminée elle est terminée dans cette
région au nord de kiev mais pas en
ukraine et ensuite c'est très compliqué
d'abord parce qu'il faut recueillir des
témoignages beaucoup de témoignages et
puis il faut aussi parfois se rendre sur
place et inspecter des immeubles qui
sont complètement détruits on a pu
suivre une équipe d'enquêteurs nous
pendant que nous étions là-bas haïr pin
il nous expliquer comment il avait
fonctionné c'est à dire qu'une dame les
avait appelés pour leur dire qu'elle
était sans nouvelles de son oncle ils se
sont donc rendus à l'appartement de son
oncle ils ont découvert que le balcon et
avait été remplacé par un énorme trou
d'obus et ils ont voulu ensuite donc
allé vérifier ce qui s'était passé dans
cet appartement mais avant ça il a fallu
faire intervenir le déminage qui a dû
hop qui a dû donc inspecté tout
l'immeuble puis l'appartement de manière
très précise et ils ont enfin pu
pénétrer à l'intérieur pour découvrir le
cadavre de cet de cet homme qui selon
eux était en train de fumer une
cigarette au balcon lorsqu'il a reçu une
requête donc tout ça prend du temps des
mines il faut savoir qu'il y en a
absolument partout dans cette région là
dans les champs sur les routes dans les
maisons parfois dans l'électroménager
même une porte de frigidaires peut être
peut être piégé
lorsque nous sommes rentrés dire pin en
voiture il ya aussi beaucoup d'obus qui
n'ont pas explosé pendant ces
bombardements et lorsque nous sommes
rentrés dire pin en voiture on a entendu
au loin alors suffisamment près pour
qu'on l'entende et concentre le souffle
mais suffisamment loin pour qu'on ne le
voit pas l'un de ces obus explosent et
parfois ils explosent sans raison
parfois quelqu'un marche dessus il y en
a encore un qui a été découvert plantées
dans le sol juste devant l'hôpital dire
pin pas plus tard que hier matin et puis
il y aussi la difficulté de recueillir
des témoignages ont notamment pour
toutes ces affaires dont on parle
beaucoup de viol des témoignages directs
c'est extrêmement compliqué parce que
les victimes ne veulent pas revivre ça
ne veulent pas forcément que leurs
familles ou leurs proches soit au
courant donc c'est très compliqué de
recueillir ces témoignages
ce qui est sûr c'est que ces enquêtes
sont extrêmement importantes puisque
c'est ce qui va permettre en fait de
savoir si il s'agit de soldats
indisciplinés sous l'emprise de l'alcool
et de la drogue et ça ça revient dans
tous les témoignages dans toutes les
villes les soldats russes et était
alcoolisé et drogué et donc il va
falloir savoir s'il s'agit de soldats
indisciplinés qui ont un groupe
collectivement perdu toute notion avec
le bien et le mal ou s'il s'agit au
contraire de soldats très disciplinés
qu'ils recevaient des ordres venus d'en
haut pour commettre ces exactions ça
c'est effectivement ces enquêtes qui
vont qui vont le démontrer vous étiez
sur place au moment du naufrage du
moskva symbole fort pour les russes
navire amiral comment on réagit à les
ukrainiens à ce moment là alors je pense
que si kiev avait été peuplés comme elle
l'était avant le avant le début de la
guerre on aurait probablement assisté à
des scènes de liesse dans la rue parce
que c'est vrai quand on discute avec les
ukrainiens on a l'impression qu'il
venait de gagner la coupe du monde de
football un s'étaient ils étaient tous
très heureux ça évidemment exacerbé le
sentiment de fierté nationale le leu
moskva c'est le navire amiral de la
flotte russe en mer noire ils portent en
plus le nom de la capitale d'ici là bas
personne n'a cru une seconde à la
version russe d'un accident tout le
monde a tout de suite et est persuadé
effectivement c'est ce qui semble se
démontrer maintenant de manière quasi
certaine que ce sont bien les ukrainiens
qui ont abattu ce bateau ils s'en sont
donné à coeur joie sur les réseaux
sociaux notamment cette image de de
vladimir poutine et de volodymyr
zelensky tous les deux à un bout de la
fameuse table géante de vladimir poutine
en train de jouer à la bataille navale
et il ya eu beaucoup de blagues comme ça
qu on circulait sur les réseaux sociaux
vous savez au début du conflit
les ukrainiens avaient édité un timbre
pour rendre hommage aux premiers
capturer de la guerre sur l'île aux
serpents acquis un navire russe donc le
moskva avait intimé l'ordre de se rendre
et les soldats ukrainien avait insulté
le commandant du navire et il y avait
donc ce timbre qui a été édité à ce
moment-là du soldat russe insultant le
navire ukrainien
que lorsque nous avons quitté kiev dans
quelques jours après après cette attaque
le timbre était rationnée il était
limitée à quatre par personne il y avait
des queues absolument interminables
devant les bureaux de poste à kiev elle
vivait dans toutes les grandes villes de
gens qui pouvaient attendre plusieurs
heures qui parfois réservé même leur
place puisqu'il avait cette possibilité
là pour le lendemain pour acheter ce
timbre suite au naufrage du mauss va
alors si vous le voulez judith vous
pouvez aussi le trouver sur internet il
coûte 2000 euros on me dit comme ça
c'est vrai que ça peut sembler une
histoire un peu amusantes en revanche il
faut quand même se rappeler qu'il ya 500
membres d'équipage qui étaient à bord du
bateau et dont on ne sait pas ce qu'ils
sont devenus puisque pour l'instant de
la russie n'a toujours pas réussi à
prouver de manière certaine qu'ils
étaient toujours en vie merci beaucoup
sylvain rousseau